failed former president Donald Trump
indicted 34 counts reportedly Donald
Trump expected to be in New York City in
court on Tuesday to be booked mugshotted
fingerprinted arraigned and subsequently
released Donald Trump has absolutely
lost his mind posting the entire night
to truth social we will look at that
many of you agree with me that Trump
will not see the inside of a prison self
or even one day but that being said this
shows that no one is above the law so
many people saying this is unprecedented
and this is not Justice no no no no no
no
if Trump was above the law that would
not be Justice and he will get his day
in court he is innocent until proven
guilty and I believe that this first
indictment out of New York City may be
the first of many with prosecutors
waiting to see will someone be the first
to indict a former president the
Associated Press reports Donald Trump
indicted expected to surrender early
next week the exact nature of the
charges is unclear as of Friday
because the indictment remains under
seal but they stem from payments made
during the 2016 campaign to silence the
claims of an extramarital sexual
encounter of course with Stormy Daniels
Trump has assailed the uh entire thing
says it's all bogus and nonsense this is
historic in every single way Donald
Trump wildly posting to truth social all
night I'm scrolling it for people to see
multiple times per hour three hours ago
and then going to
eventually a lot of posts three hours
ago then of eventually getting to seven
hours ago which would have put it at 3
30 in the morning and nine hours ago 1
30 just posting posting I I'm gonna stop
scrolling because people are going to
get dizzy Donald Trump initially
reacting to the indictment with a
misspelled Post in which he says he has
been indicated not only is this the
first time that a former president has
been indicated by a grand jury this is
the first time a grand jury has
indicated any president and of course it
is beyond parody that even this Trump
can't string together a reasonable
statement about Trump posting to truth
quote and by the way there's capital
letters all over this thing I'm not even
going to mention each time Trump
randomly capitalizes these thugs in
radical left monsters have just
indicated the 45th president of the
United States of America and the leading
Republican candidate by far for the 2024
nomination for president here he engages
caps lock and says this is an attack on
our country the likes of which has never
been seen before
remember Trump was a one-man crime spree
as president the likes of which the
country has never seen before Trump
continuing in all capital letters it is
likewise A continuing attack on our once
free and fair elections no it's not the
USA is now a third world nation a nation
in serious decline so sad then Trump
putting out a more formal statement
which was no less unhinged I won't read
the entire thing I'm not going to
subject you to that but in the first
paragraph of course he calls the
prosecution a political persecution as
well as election interference he
includes the term Witch Hunt and many
other things in the second paragraph he
says wrongly that Democrats cheated and
have stolen of course it was Trump who
tried to steal the 2020 election in the
third paragraph he says this has never
been done in Nations history that's true
but remember there has never been a
one-man crime spree like Trump in the
Oval Office in American history there
has never been a President Who
surrounded himself
with so many reliably crooked people
then he attacks Alvin Bragg linking him
to George Soros and lastly he says this
will backfire on Joe Biden of course Joe
Biden has nothing to do with it Tuesday
booking an arraignment expected you know
on Tuesday big strong guy with tears in
his eyes might go up to Trump and say
sir I'll be taking your mug shot now
please don't do anything stupid this
shows no one is above the law that is
Justice although Trump will not serve a
day of prison time the hope is that this
is only the beginning one of our
continued sponsors is ground news an app
and website that Aggregates local and
international news sources to show you
how breaking news is being reported
around the world it has become a go-to
resource for me right now I'm looking at
a story about residents in Ohio
reporting medical symptoms after the
train derailment ground news shows the
headline from The Washington Post owned
by Jeff Bezos says East Palestine
residents should look to agent orange
victims the headline from The Epic Times
a radical right-wing Outlet says Federal
officials enter 500 East Palestine homes
after toxic train crash I also like that
you can sort things by factuality
location and bias check out ground news
for free at Ground dot News slash Pacman
if you find ground news as useful as I
do subscribe for unlimited access the
link is down below